governors have mandated generally not
all of them but most of them has said
there will be no elective surgeries
because we need to clear the hospitals
so that we can have beds and equipment
for for people with respiratory failure
because of kovat well the unintended
consequence of that is that cancer
patients are foregoing treatment and a
lot of hospitals are are on the verge of
bankruptcy because elective surgery was
a key part of their economic model so
they've made things worse by trying to
make things better so with all this in
mind let's pretend kibby's president
it's 2020 america has some sort of you
know libertarian I don't like to say you
libertarian utopia because I don't think
libertarians really believe in utopia in
the way that progressives tend to
believe in it but we have you know some
sort of more Liberty minded state maybe
that the plan if the founders had
planned and you're president and you
start getting all these communicates and
messages about coronavirus is the first
thing that you do as a president to tell
all of the governors you guys just
handle this and when you need help you
call us but I'm not gonna do anything
with that
what about would that be the sort of
Liberty take on what the president
should be doing right now it would it
would definitely be federalism but but
to take it even a step further localism
and even individualism Iran famously
said that the most discriminated
minority is the individual and I think
that even at the local level there can
be tyranny if governments get too full
of themselves and in the key to really
complex problems things you don't know
anything about is tapping into local
knowledge and problem-solving and and
this is what this is what governors are
getting wrong so I don't think
federalism is going to solve a problem
you know that the libertarian joke is
that we're conspiring to take over the
government so that we'll leave you alone
yes that's I guess that would be my
mandate if I was president god help me
but
that that that that it gets back to the
humility thing and you see this playing
out in very practical ways governor's
have mandated generally not all of them
but most of them has said there will be
no elective surgeries because we need to
clear the hospitals so that we can have
beds and equipment for for people with
respiratory failure because of kovat
well the unintended consequence of that
is that cancer patients are foregoing
treatment and a lot of hospitals are are
on the verge of bankruptcy because
elective surgery was a key part of their
economic model so they've made things
worse by trying to make things better
the only people that would know for sure
what the right policy would be to make
sure that a hospital was safe and
well-run and had capacity would be to
let doctors and patients and hospital
administrators in that community figure
that stuff out for themselves that's got
to be the way that we get out of this
mess now that we've created it but that
would be that would be my take but but
is the inherent problem with that that
the blue state governors and and the
lefties more generally they don't view
paying for these things or hospitals
having to you know pay people or any of
these things as necessary it's sort of
oh well do whatever you're supposed to
do as they define it and then we'll just
we'll pay for it meaning we'll just
magically make up numbers so so logic is
just sort of coming against like a black
hole in a certain regard there's you
know that I think a lot of governors are
suddenly discovering that if they close
down all the businesses there won't be
any revenue to pay that at all it's
incredible and now they're of course
going to the federal government begging
for a bill out there and I hope I hope
we don't give it to them because that'll
just reward really bad behavior but
there is like a shocking naivete about
and I said this earlier how does food
get on the table but but where does
where does all that revenue come from
that funds all of these programs how do
hospitals stay in business it's it's
very much a market that allows for that
where you have customers and you have
people selling services and you know
some reason we don't think that that's
appropriate in health care but it's
essential if you actually want access to
a doctor when when you're diagnosed with
cancer and no amount of empty government
promises are a substitute for that and
we're gonna learn this right now all of
these generous unemployment benefits all
of people that are on Medicaid and
Medicare
these programs are gonna get squeezed
like never before because there's just
gonna be a total collapse in government
revenue and they're hoping that the feds
bailed them out but the feds don't have
any money either so we're gonna we're
gonna print it and there's all sorts of
like this would be a different program
about what's gonna happen when all that
stuff happens but everyone thinks that
that resources are just like this
exhausting out there then magically is
there and all we got to do is read avoid
it you know it's gonna disappear and
then we're gonna discover what that that
sort of social justice model is gonna
lead to and it's it's gonna make
everybody less safe everybody less
healthy everybody more hungry and and I
hope there's some ownership of that but
we'll see so going on the assumption
there is in ownership of that because
that doesn't seem to be how inertia
works or there or there might at least
be states that that sort of own it
themselves so you know Florida and Texas
for example with zero state income tax
are doing nice jobs balancing their
budgets and I do sense there's sort of a
idea floating around the internet right
now that in effect what New York in
California particularly are doing is
they're trying to absolutely tank their
own economies because they're they're so
screwed and I say this as someone that
grew up in New York and now lives in
California that they have so screwed
themselves despite the 13 percent income
tax that I pay here in California on top
of la you know city tax that they have
no way of getting out so it's like
destroy it let's let's blow up the whole
thing knowing the feds will have to come
in and clean up the mess I know you're
not for that but
do you think that that's actually
possible that that's really what they're
like Newsome's really sitting around
going we're looking at the numbers
there's no way out of this and let's
just blow up the whole damn thing and
force it we'll stick it to trump
something like that yeah I mean I think
it's I think it's it's clearly part of
their strategy they they don't have any
they don't seem to have any concern
about actually cleaning up their own
house so they're they're gonna look for
that bailout but let me we talked about
conspiracy theories let me take it a
step further yeah james james Clyburn
who is nancy pelosi is number three in
the house in early March when they were
debating that first trillion dollar bill
which turned into a 2.2 trillion dollar
bill he said to his colleagues this is
an opportunity to remake America the way
that we want to see it happen and I
think there's a method to this madness
when you give people such extravagant
stravagant unemployment benefits that
employers can't hire them back because
they're making a ton more money being
unemployed that sounds like something
that a AOC would love to see because she
she told us all not to go back to our
jobs yeah she does there's no value in
work basically yeah and and we all know
that that's economically ignorant but
but what if this is a process to
radically expand the welfare state I
give you if you're putting a third of
Americans out of work and you're giving
them these generous benefits at what
point is any Republican or Democrat
gonna roll that back they never they
never get rolled back temporary poke
programs become permanent but you know
the other piece of this which I think is
even more ominous is this this tracking
system that they're developing where if
you if you do decide to go to a
restaurant there's gonna be some
government bureaucrat there wanting your
information so that they can get in
contact with you later that sounds like
something that Communist Chinese would
do well you know if we want to do the
conspiracy thing then it's like wow
maybe China unleash this knowing all
these stupid things that we would then
do to ourselves
well it's it is sort of I I don't know
if they did it on purpose
but if we do it dot the Chinese model
based on on by the way huge government
failures that originated in China one
government failure after another and all
the sudden we're like let's be like
China then then America is done like
we're we're just done if we're not gonna
push back but but to your point like the
only way that the Governor of California
and the governor of New York are held
accountable is if the people do it and
it's got to be bottom-up the same logic
that applies to markets applies to
political pressure and I'm not talking
about voting I'm talking about the
people that drive public opinion that
actually shape what politicians will do
tomorrow that's where this revolution
has to start it's got to be peaceful
it's got to be civilly disobedience and
you're seeing it in in the streets and
on the beaches today people are like
we're done you guys lied to us you told
us that we were flattening the curve and
now you won't let us out of our houses
we're just done if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell